kyrie on a personal note you have said
that you are fasting for ramadan which
for those who are unaware means no food
no water from sun up to sun down
how do you muster the energy to go out
and score 34 points with very little
nutrition in your body
well it's a journey with god and i'm not
alone in this i have brothers and
sisters all around the world that are
fasting with me
uh we we hold our prayers and our
meditations very sacred and when you
come out here i mean god's inside me
guys inside you guys inside all of us so
i'm walking with faith man that's all
that matters and when i get a chance to
do this in this type of arena and
showcase my talents that have been
granted me strictly from god i'm humble
so he's not letting me score 34 the must
win i'll tell you that congratulations
guys thanks brother
all right thank you jared kyrie irving
we should be more positive too stan you
hear that we're going to be that way the
rest
of the playoffs there'll be no fasting
on our part though
do i look like i've ever it for stan van
gundy jared greenberg and the rest of
our tnt crew brian anderson saying so
long from brooklyn let's send it to
ernie johnson in atlanta